Stranger Things season 3 is an official Internet-breaker,
but recently, the beloved series garnered
attention for all the wrong reasons: It turns
out the new season includes a little production
error that slipped right past most viewers.
As far as spoilers are concerned, we won't
be getting into anything major here, but we
will be touching upon some general story points.
Consider yourself warned!
Hawk-eyed fans of the show spotted a continuity
error during the fifth episode of season three,
which hit Netflix on July 4th.
The episode, entitled "Chapter Five: The Flayed,"
finds the gang loitering around the local
hospital, where Nancy is visiting Doris Driscoll,
a woman linked to the season's big supernatural
threat.
While Nancy gets herself into a spot of trouble,
the rest of the gang hangs out in the waiting
room.
That's when Eleven uses her powers to short-circuit
the hospital vending machine to give Mike
and Lucas lots of snacks to share.
Because that's just what good friends do.
Trying to win back Eleven after acting like
a jerk, Mike gives her a few M&M's as a peace
offering.
But look closely at that handful of chocolate
candies.
Do you see what we see?
There's a red M&M.
This season of Stranger Things is set in 1985,
a time when red M&M's were impossible to find.
People born in the era of plentiful red M&M's
probably didn't think twice about this tiny
little detail.
But the fact is, Mars Inc., the makers of
the candy-shell-coated chocolates, actually
discontinued that particular color of M&M
back in the 1970s.
And they didn't bring back red M&M's until
1987.
The company discontinued that particular color
because of the so-called "red dye scare" of
1976.
That's when the Food and Drug Administration
published a study linking common food additives
Red Dye #2 and Red Dye #4 to cancer, ruling
that red dyes weren't safe for consumption.
Though Mars used a different red food dye
to make its red M&M's, the company nonetheless
replaced red M&Ms with orange shortly after
the FDA made its ruling.
The company hoped this would calm people down
and keep business booming.
Eleven years later, red M&M's came back and
never left.
So unless Mike has his own very special power,
there's absolutely no way he could have given
Eleven a red M&M in 1985, unless the vending
machine at Hawkins Memorial Hospital hadn't
been restocked in almost a decade.
"Boy I really hope someone got fired for that blunder."
Of course, anything is possible in that town.
At the end of the day, this goof isn't half
as bad as Game of Thrones' infamous coffee
cup gaffe during its eighth and final season.
That incident involved a paper coffee cup
ending up on set, widely believed to be from
Starbucks, but actually from a local café
in Northern Ireland where the series was filmed.
The now-notorious cup ended up making it into
the episode's final cut, and no one involved
with the show noticed…until it was too late.
Compared to that mistake, the blip in Stranger
Things is small potatoes.
And even though Netflix and the Stranger Things
team have yet to address the error, the official
M&M's Twitter account offered up its own explanation:
"Clearly, in 1985 Red M&M's were around...in
the Upside Down."
Well-played, M&M's.
What a delicious little joke.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Stranger
Things are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.